what's going on reject nation Greg Alba
here and John Humphrey over here today
we're gonna do a special patreon video
request one of our War tears over at
patreon is whatever video you request
would there be a reaction or a review of
something yeah we will do it today is
another reaction they usually are when
they Rosa para so far as I'm when I'm
asked for discussion video hey man
but but that's okay we can get more
discussions down the line yeah this is a
video from Jeff bearskin Peterson that
he sent over to us Jeff Bs and Jeff
bearskin he's Indian he's and he's like
this is like you know Indian humor the
authority is was engine engine I allowed
to use that word I don't think I'm
allowed to you with the with the
standing is on that I don't I don't
think I'm allowed to so antiquated that
I don't think it's you know I still have
white relatives that think saying
Orientals okay oh yeah I don't know
anyway this videos from the the channel
the 1491 it's called slapping medicine
man came out in 2011 so it's trending on
YouTube right now relevant video slaps
let's let's see what what this is all
going on I've been to a lot of white
doctors no one cared he told me you know
what's going on with me basically I
think I know no singing voice
[Music]
you know you know you know I don't know
what to do
[Music]
I also have a problem work people don't
want to be around me you know well I'm
having trouble that work too
I keep getting fired for my jobs they
just don't like me
you know they say they walk away when I
come up - who are you gonna work why
gossip from time to time you know
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
these are all the people who made it or
all the ones who started in the - you
can tell yeah like those names would
match those three actors yeah Joey Barra
Jeff when he sent this over so much
disclosures of like I don't think you'll
really get it or find it funny that was
I mean you know I unless I missed
something that joke itself is pretty
simple but I thought it was pretty yeah
I miss like simple sketches like this
yeah when's he gonna slap them and it's
just like setting up a camera and just
like randomly like little easy things to
shoot like simple sketches and here have
like 2011 so it's rare you see something
like that uploader now that gets that
popular yeah this has almost a million
views oh boy
and that was so funny and I couldn't
help but think of Tony Gill Tony go with
that one guy I suddenly dawned on me oh
it's that Native American side and Tony
yeah tree Z you know you see the gamer
on Twitch that guy horse like the water
is always super chilly guys say looks
like Cisco from flash yeah he showing
all the time yeah yes Tony what he's up
tonight I think
and I've always known he's like has a
par Native American but I've always
thought like when people say part Native
American
that he's like Isis a little part Native
American like 6% yeah yeah that's right
that's what I usually imagine someone
tells me that and then I'm like looking
at this guy then I'm thinking about the
other people or Native American that
I've met and I'm like oh that's why I
Tony's just the way he is
he's Native American like his
personality just totally reminded me of
these guys more than just the looks yeah
that was so funny that I loved that dry
type of awkward offbeat humor they had
going on the whole yeah sort of going
the complete opposite route of like the
the medicine man mysticism and it's just
like now I'm just just slap yeah yeah
like simple but but effective and I like
a good simple but effective yeah cuz you
know you see like the name it's true
because in news of the Native American
like Indian bits yeah yeah let's do
something that's really something rugs
robbers yeah
slap some common sense right across your
face I don't know who the the guy was
that was the the chubby one the
overweight one which one is Tito Ibarra
I'm knowing that's probably him because
yeah his timing was really good
yeah the livery was awesome that was a
really funny sketch dude these guys
still active in uploading and stuff cuz
this is from this has almost a million
views it's jungle I wanna give you a
song from 2011 they barely upload now no
it's too bad I was so funny though I
want to see more of their videos well
guys subscribe to the 1491 so I wouldn't
hit the subscribe button it's cool man
it's like a bunch of Native Americans
and a white dude just the token white
guy in every group Dave Chappelle bet
he's like the craziest one in the group
they make him the guy for the white
jokes yeah yeah all right well thanks
Jeff for introducing that to us that's
very different very different type of
group of people in a channel then we've
been exposed to yet I feel like my
knowledge has range and so is my
vocabulary apparently God you got a lot
a lot of more words a lot more a lot of
more words and what a good good more
words more even more than before well
Jeff fair skinned Peterson oh yeah since
this [ __ ] hilarious
[ __ ] sketch I don't think you're
gonna really have to be drunk off your
ass or something yeah I was banging this
chick came across this video I love my
youtube on [ __ ] slapping people but
that my cousin called me and I had to go
get in the mechanic shop because you'll
start one place you'll be like I know
what we're talking about and then like
halfway and you'll be like wait a second
yeah where are we but he catches himself
oh yeah and then yeah and then we catch
ourselves and then we're back at it just
a deep thinker man I like Jeff a lot hey
guys subscribe to the real rejects click
that notification bell he is dat John
Humphrey on twit and insta go check out
our patreon if you like there's a lot of
stuff over there I sorted through over a
hundred videos yesterday to put together
a special video itself yeah windows
there's a lot of footage over I pagers
alright now join us